لاحداث غزه حول ذلك ينضم الينا من رام
الله الدكتور هاني المصري مدير مركز
مسارات لابحاث السياسات والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه دكتور هاني ماذا تقرا في هذه
الاحداث حتى
اللحظه ونحن طربنا من تقريبا مرور 24 ساعه
على هذه الاغتيالات
ونحن طبعا نتحدث عن اغتيالات تعرض لها
قياده سرايا القدس الذراع العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وكذلك اسرهم الذين كانوا
معهم وجيرانهم هناك عدد من النساء
والاطفال
اقرا في ضبط النفس الفلسطيني بانه افشل
يعني التكتيك الاسرائيلي الذي كان يرمي
الى تفكيك وحده الفصائل الفلسطينيه من
خلال استفراد يعني العمليه في قادم الجهاد
الاسلامي مع عائلاتهم
ولدرجه ان عندما صرح وزير اسرائيلي ينتمي
الى الليكود وحذر يعني باغتيال السنوار
والضيف وبخه نتنياهو وهذا يوضح ان تكتيك
الفصل وافرق تسد الذي تتبعه القوات
الاسرائيليه واضح جدا في هذه العمليه
مثلما كان واضحا في عمليات سابقه عدم الرد
الانفعالي والثاني والانتقام يدل على ان
هناك
تنسيق فلسطيني هناك وحده موقف هناك محاوله
لاختيار التوقيت المناسب والهدف المناسب
لان الرد المباشر كما كان يحصل في العاده
كان يحصل في وقت فيه قوات الاحتلال في
اقصى استعداد واكثر ترقب وقدره على يعني
الرد ليس هذا هو الوقت المناسب وامل ان
تستمر يعني المقاومه الفلسطينيه في ضبط
نفسها اكثر من يوم ويومين وايام هذا حتى
يعني من خلال متابعتك
يعني من خلال متابعتك لنعرف المشاهدين
ايضا على ما يجري هل هذا يعتبر نهجا
مختلفا عن ما درجه عليه فصائل المقاومه في
العاده وان كان الامر كذلك فما الذي يدفع
اليه
انا اعتقد انه فعلا عن النهج المختلفا
كانت في العاده الفصائل تقوم برده فعل
فوريه يعني خاصه على عمليات مثل هذا النوع
واذا تم التاخر يكون تاخر لعده ساعات الان
نشارف على مرور 24 ساعه ولم ترد الفصائل
ولكنها اكدت بان الرد ات ولكن اين وكيف
وما وكيف يمكن ان يكون في اسعار صواريخ من
قطاع غزه عبر عمليات في الضفه او داخل
اسرائيل او من اي مكان اخر هذا ما بقي
غامضا ويجب ان تبقى قوات الاحتلال مستنفره
والجبهه الداخليه مستنزفه ولاطول وقت ممكن
وهذا بحد ذاته نوع من انواع الرد يعني رد
الفعل الثار المباشر العاطفي ليس هو احسن
طريقه يعني خاصه ان يبدو ان اسرائيل تريد
توجيه ضربه قويه جدا للمقاومه ولشعبنا في
قطاع غزه
ان نفوت الفرصه عليها لان نظريه الردع
الاسرائيليه تضررت بالاونه الاخيره بشكل
كبير وتحولت الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي
وصفت بانها الاكثر تطرفا والاكثر عدوانيه
وانها الحكومه التي تخطط لحسم الصراع مع
الفلسطينيين بسرعه وبصوره مختلفه عما
فعلته الحكومات السابقه بدات بانها مرتبكه
ومفككه وغير قادره على الرد برايك
المقاومه فصائل المقاومه ما هي الاهداف
التي تسعى اليها سواء من خلال ردها الذي
قالت انه اتن او توقيت هذا الرد او تاجيله
ماء في رايك من الاهداف التي تريدها من كل
ذلك
انا
اعتقد تريد اختي
ار
الاحداث هناك يعني بنك كبير للاهداف سواء
من خلال اطلاق الصواريخ على غلاف قطاع غزه
او على مدى اكبر يمكن ان يصل الى تل ابيب
وحيفا والقدس يمكن ان يستهدف مناطق
حيويه واهله بالسكان يمكن ان يستهدف مواقع
عسكريه يمكن ان يكون الرد من خلال عمليات
ينفذها يعني مجموعات فدائيه في الضفه
الغربيه سواء في قطاع غزه او في داخل يعني
اسرائيل يمكن ان يكون الرد من جنوب لبنان
كما حصل بالاونه الاخيره من خلال اطلاق
صواريخ يمكن ان يكون الرد من كل هذه
المناطق ولكن اعتقد حتى الان لا يوجد طرف
يريد مواجهه مفتوحه وشامله ولكن هذه
الاجواء وهذا الحجم من التطرف الاسرائيلي
والازمه الداخليه العميقه التي تمر بها
اسرائيل يمكن ان تدفعها الى تصدير ازمتها
اكثر واكثر في محاوله لتوحيد يعني
الاسرائيليين كما اليوم هناك وحده داخل
الحكومه
بنكفير سحب اعتراضه ومقاطعته للحكومه
ونواب حزبه سحبوا مقاطعتهم للكنيست وحتى
المعارضه ايدت يعني العدوان الاسرائيلي
المجزره الاسرائيليه لان ما قدره هو مجزره
بحق عائلات يعني المدنيين والاطفال
والنساء هم الاغلبيه العظمى من الضحايا
سواء من الشهداء او من الجرحى وبالتالي
اسرائيل التي تقول انها ستفحص لماذا تم
استهداف المدنيين وكانها لا تعرف هي تعرف
ما فعلت بالضبط
في هذه العمليات بكل دقه هؤلاء الذين اشرت
اليهم بنجافير وغيره هل تعتقد انهم
سينجحون وهل يريدون هم مزيدا من التصعيد
ان يريدون ان تظل الامور في هذه الحدود
اعتقد ان هناك اطراف بالحكومه ليس فقط حزب
بنكفيرش حتى جزء من الليكود يريدون حرب
مفتوحه مع الفلسطينيين يتصورون انهم
قادرون على الحسم وبسرعه وبطريقه مختلفه
عن ما فعلته الحكومات السابقه ولكن الجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه
الدوله العميقه في اسرائيل لا تنجر معهم
وخاصه انها تحسب حساب الخسائر الاسرائيليه
تحسب حساب ردات الفعل الدوليه تحسب حساب
الموقف الامريكي الذي لا يريد مواجهه
مفتوحه يمكن ان تفتح الطريق على حرف
اقليميه ويضع قيود وهناك قيود اقليميه
ودوليه على حرب اقليميه لان المنطقه لا
ينقصها ما يجري في السودان لا ينقصها ما
يجري واليمن والاهم ما يجري في اوكرانيا
من حرب كبيره جدا يعني لها تداعيات كبيره
على كل المناطق بما فيها منطقتنا شكرا
جزيلا لكم رام الله هاني المصري مدير مركز
مسارات الابحاث السياسات والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه